I, if it's okay,
can I ask about how you met your wife, Phyllis?
Yes, yeah, we met a wee bit back ago.
We were teenagers and we met
at my grandmother's house in her finished basement.
It was my other cousin's sweet 16 birthday party
and she came with a friend and it was, you know
kind of infatuation and love at first sight.
She has a great warmth about her.
She's a nurse practitioner and doing a lot of work
right now with dealing with everything
we're dealing with and COVID.
She's, you know, one of the heroes of the family.
That's for sure.
She's been on the front lines during the pandemic.
Am I correct?
In New York?
Yes, yes, I mean, in her line of work,
which is often dealing with the families
of the patients that are,
as well as the patients themselves, you know,
it's that, that she bridges that gap
of helping manage those very difficult decisions.
So it is, it's hero work, you know, it really is.
I love your story, in your grandmother's basement,
at a sweet 16
I can't escape it.
It's like, oh my God, I gotta write this a little.
I got to do the David Lynch version.
(laughs)
You know, but that's not the truth.
I want to see the original and the David Lynch version.
And you have two children together, your son, Daniel
and your daughter, Julia.
And she's an actress and even been on Broadway.
What advice, I know that you guys really communicate
with your kids, what did you guide her through?
You know, she had, she's done,
she did the national tour of "Flashdance."
So the Jennifer Beals' role, it was a big thing for her
and got to go to New Zealand.
And it was awesome.
The guidance, I mean, it's tough, you know,
you grew up in it even more than I did.
I always kind of kept one foot in
and one foot out, living back in New York and you know
you want to nurture those creative juices
and you don't want to thwart them, it's,
but do as I say, not as I do didn't work,
you know, but she's super talented
and I think fairly grounded.
I'd like to say that about both my kids
and you know, my upbringing was that way too.
So I was very fortunate to navigate.
And nowadays, I don't know how you deal
with everyone with a camera is,
everyone with a phone is a paparazzi.
I mean, I don't even know that kind of pressure,
you know, but fortunately, well, you and I,
we came out okay.
I'm glad you think so.
I thought you were perfect then, you're perfect now
and everything in between, as I said before.
I have been looking forward to this
in ways I can't even describe
because you really have been this person
that I've grown up with and I just admire, love,
do it for Johnny forever and "Karate Kid," and everything
and you do exude such goodness.
It's no wonder your wife and you have that story
and you have remained so full of grace and this
"Cobra Kai" is a lesson to everyone
in our industry, of how it can be done.
Thank you for, for the support, for the,
giving it to the show and just the big embrace we're getting
from everyone that's in this world right now,
it's pretty awesome.
Well, rightfully so.
Thank you, Ralph Macchio,
"Cobra Kai," season three, it's streaming on Netflix now.
(upbeat music)